nous en sommes maintenant la période de
questions réponses orales que je cède la
parole à monsieur le chef de
l'opposition officielle
le québec est un pays riche
il se classe septième parmi les pays les
plus riches au monde
il devance même la suède et l'allemagne
le monde et ressources naturelles
abondantes une situation géographique
enviable et surtout une population dont
le savoir faire et la créativité sont
reconnus mondialement
mais il ya aussi des défis importants
notre démographie par exemple nous
devons être encore plus performant pour
faire progresser le québec le
développement du nord et la stratégie
maritime ne seront pas suffisants je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin et plus
vite qu'il faut doter le québec d'une
véritable politique du plein emploi
j'offre ma collaboration au premier
ministre je lui propose de convier des
acteurs socio-économiques à un important
rendez vous où nous pourrons tous
contribué à définir les moyens et les
priorités d'un véritable plan croissance
durable est ce que le premier ministre
est ouvert à la tenue d'un grand forum
économique dès septembre prochain pour
doter le québec d'une véritable
politique économie
monsieur l'après midi
sur le président devrait commencer par
encore une fois sincèrement souhaité la
bienvenue à notre collègue le chef de
l'opposition officielle à l'assemblée
également souligné la participation de
plusieurs de nos collègues ici à la
course à la chefferie le député de
lac-saint-jean des petites
marie-victorin députée de rosemont ce
fut court mais bon député de vachon
monsieur pierre séré également qui a
participé à cette course si on sait que
ce sont des épisodes qui sont exigeants
et notre collègue bien sûr en sort
vainqueur et on le félicite pour cela
maintenant il aura remarqué notre
collègue également que au jour même où
il pose cette question
aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé
l'investissement industriel le plus
important dans la région de québec des
dix dernières années la consolidation et
la création de 400 emplois avec un
investissement de medicago pour 245
millions de dollars
il aura également
il aura également noté la création de
son entreprise de plus de 68 mille
emplois monsieur le président depuis
notre arrivée au gouvernement majorité
des emplois du secteur privé majorité a
maintenant un bon une bonne portion
temps plein donc clairement le québec
oui à des défis mais le québec est
également sur la bonne voie je prends
note de son attention à la question
démographique je trouve que c'est
effectivement une eau plus grand défi
parce que notre population active
diminue
il faut donc accueillir les bras ouverts
les immigrants le spam surprise
il faut également bien former la
main-d'oeuvre s'assurer qu'on a une
bonne adéquation entre les compétences
requises et des emplois disponibles
il faut poser une multitude de gestes et
oui le plan nord et vous la stratégie
maritime ça fait partie du plan de
développement économique les pme la
réforme de la fiscalité des finances
publiques saines et équilibrées et une
dette publique sous contrôle ses seules
fins économiques du gouvernement
il a commencé à fonctionner il va
continuer à fonctionner
tu étais des dernières semaines ne
montre que la protection de nos belles
entreprises n'est plus que jamais
pertinente que l'on pense à alcan
bombardier au cirque du soleil
1 106 lavalin et ce matin tembec qui
annonce la fermeture de trois usines à
senneterre b1 et la sarre 350 emplois
perdus
est ce que le premier ministre reconnaît
l'urgence d'agir pour mieux protéger nos
fleurons et nos sièges sociaux au
monsieur le premier ministre
mais brièvement notre collègue mentionne
tembec et comme lui bien sûr on est tous
surpris par cette nouvelle
il faut savoir que notre collègue 2011
la forêt la faune et des parcs est
active sur ce dossier depuis plusieurs
mois a accordé du bois supplémentaires à
tembec s'occupe également de calculer
leurs coûts d'approvisionnement
spécifiquement pour leurs opérations en
abitibi dans le cas inverse examen du
régime forestier
mais là monsieur le président pour
attirer et garder les sièges sociaux au
québec il ya intégré dian absolument
essentiel c'est la stabilité économique
politique et financière alors
effectivement une seule président lorsqu
on milite pour le maintien de
l'appartenance du québec à la fédération
canadienne
lorsqu'on minutes pour des finances
publiques saines et équilibrées une
dette sous contrôle
on agit dans le sens où il faut agir
pour garder et attirer nos sièges
sociaux euros comprenant à terre le
sécheur de répulsion
le premier ministre tiendra un sommet
économique pour le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean le 18 juin
prochain
il reconnaît donc l'importance de réunir
les décideurs auto le même table pour
mieux développer l'économie de la région
alors si la formule est bonne pour une
région ce premier ministre pourquoi ne
serait-elle pas bonnes pour le reste du
québec
merci mon collègue d'abord mentionné
satis au sommet qui aura lieu le 18 juin
d'ailleurs nos collègues députés
régionaux y sont conviés et je crois
qu'on avait là beaucoup de matériel
parce que 95 plus de 95 mémoire déposé
nombreuses suggestions intéressantes
maintenant j'ai également parlé de
concertation avec les bidasses syndicaux
que j'ai rencontré récemment et on a
convié notre collègue était déjà à
l'oeuvre là dessus de créer une table de
débats permanente sur les orientations
des priorités développement économique
de fiscalité avec des représentants du
patronat et du mouvement syndical et
bien sûr des acteurs du gouvernement
donc on est dans cette direction mais ce
qui est rassurant monsieur le président
c'est voir une région comme la nôtre
comme le saguenay lac saint jean qui
fait face à des défis importants décidé
de se prendre en main et de se réunir à
une échelle qui permette de sortir de là
avec des exemples concrètes précises et
rapidement mise en place
trois autres volontaires touchant
profession
le président a remercié ce premier
ministre vous le savez ce sont des
milliers de pères et de mères de
familles qui viennent de perdre leur
emploi chez bombardier chez davy au
siège social d'alcan et ce matin chez
tembec
ce sont des épreuves difficiles à vivre
pour les familles touchées alors je
réitère mon invitation monsieur le
premier ministre
acceptez-vous notre main tendue sur le
1er mai
produit par les développements
économiques avec mon collègue avec le
chef de la deuxième opposition avec les
représentants de québec solidaire
là dessus bien sûr la porte est grande
ouverte mais on veut également poser des
gestes concrets il cite encore le cas
des familles de tembec est vraiment
monsieur le président on pense tous à
eux il ya elle ce matin
mais ici que faut-il faire se réunir
autour d'une table et faire un événement
public ou aller directement en région
par les entreprises vérifiez les
garanties d'approvisionnement vérifier
les politiques du bureau de
provisionnement abois et s'assurer que
cette entreprise puisse reprendre ses
activités le plus vite possible france
que si on demandait aux familles
d'abitibi touchés par cette annonce
il préférait dans blick le gouvernement
soit à 9 concrètement sur le terrain des
entreprises